This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There are two kinds of challenges we face. One kind involves a novel problem. We don't know why we are sick. A new disease suddenly sweeps the world and it doesn't have a cure. Novel challenges call for discovery. Invention. As a species, we are very good at coming up with such discoveries.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们面临的挑战有两种。一种涉及全新的问题。我们不知道自己为什么会生病。一种新的疾病突然席卷全球，而且没有治愈方法。新的挑战需要发现和发明。作为一个物种，我们非常擅长做出这样的发现。
But many of the setbacks in our lives are not caused by such problems. They are caused by problems whose solutions were discovered a long time ago. Think about the leading causes of death in most countries. They are connected to smoking, diet, and sedentary lifestyles. We know what we ought to do to live better. We should eat right and exercise, get a good night's rest, live within our means.
但我们生活中的许多挫折并非由这类问题引起。它们是由那些很久以前就已经发现解决方案的问题引起的。想想大多数国家的主要死亡原因。它们与吸烟、饮食和久坐不动的生活方式有关。我们知道为了生活得更好，我们应该做什么。我们应该健康饮食、锻炼身体、保证充足的睡眠、量入为出。
So why is it so hard to actually do those things? What do you think of the life? Some of us figure out that we have two selves and that they are in conflict and this is a challenge we need to resolve. But some of us go through life without paying a lot of attention to this fact or trying to find ways to overcome it. This week on Hidden Brain, how to engineer our lives and our minds to do what we know is good for us. Think about the resolutions you made this year. Did you decide to read more, work out more often, quit smoking? If you're like most people, you'll probably abandon your resolutions within a few weeks. Change is hard. Katie Milkman is a behavioral scientist at the Wharton School. In her new book, How to
那么，为什么真正做到这些事情如此困难呢？你如何看待生活？我们中的一些人发现自己有两个自我，它们处于冲突之中，这是一个我们需要解决的挑战。但我们中的一些人过着生活，却没有过多关注这一事实，也没有试图寻找克服它的方法。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨如何设计我们的生活和思维，以做我们知道对自己有益的事情。想想你今年做出的决定。你是否决定多读书、多锻炼、戒烟？如果你和大多数人一样，你可能会在几周内放弃你的决定。改变是困难的。凯蒂·米尔克曼是沃顿商学院的行为科学家。在她的新书《如何改变》中，
Change, she studies how we can use the mind to combat the limitations of the mind. Katie Milkman, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Katie, we're going to tackle some of the biggest questions facing us as individuals, communities and nations. We'll talk about how to overcome people's hesitancy to get vaccinated and how to get around the challenges of meeting our health goals. But I want to start our conversation at a more basic level by understanding the forces within our minds that make it difficult to do the things that we know are good for us. These everyday mental limitations are the building blocks of many of the problems we confront
她研究了我们如何利用思维来克服思维的局限性。凯蒂·米尔克曼，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我。凯蒂，我们将探讨作为个人、社区和国家所面临的一些最大问题。我们将讨论如何克服人们接种疫苗的犹豫，以及如何绕过实现健康目标的挑战。但我希望从一个更基础的层面开始我们的对话，了解我们思维中那些让我们难以做到我们知道对自己有益的事情的力量。这些日常的思维局限性是我们所面临的许多问题的基石
in the world. I want to start with one of the most common problems, the problem of distraction. We walk into a room, we can't remember why we're there. We mean to make an important phone call, we get sidetracked. You once experienced a spectacular moment of distraction on a bus. Can you tell me what happened? Yes, I take the bus to work most days, at least I did pre-pandemic, and I was going to work my usual route,
在世界上。我想从最常见的问题之一开始，即分心的问题。我们走进一个房间，却记不起为什么去那里。我们打算打一个重要的电话，却被别的事情岔开了。你曾经在公交车上经历过一次极其引人注目的分心时刻。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？是的，我大多数时候都坐公交车上班，至少在疫情前是这样，我走的是通常的上班路线，
but I had a suitcase with me because I had a trip planned. I put the suitcase up on the side of the bus when I got in the place where you can place your luggage, I took my seat, and then I got off the bus as usual at my stop, and I forgot to grab my suitcase. My computer wasn't it, lots of things I needed for the trip, I was about to take, weren't it?
但我带了一个手提箱，因为我计划了一次旅行。我上车时把手提箱放在了公交车侧面可以放行李的地方，我坐到了座位上，然后像往常一样在我的站点下了车，但我忘了拿我的手提箱。我的电脑不在里面，我即将进行的旅行所需的许多东西都不在里面？
I had to go into Wharton and teach my MBA class, so I didn't really have a lot of time to deal with the disaster. And I will just say, my husband is my hero. I called him, I told him what had happened. He went and stood on the bus route, it was a bus loop around the city, and he intercepted every bus. Oh my god.
我得去沃顿商学院教我的MBA课程，所以我真的没有太多时间处理这场灾难。我只想说，我的丈夫是我的英雄。我打电话给他，告诉了他发生的事情。他去公交车路线上站着，那是一条环绕城市的公交线路，他拦截了每一辆公交车。天哪。
That stopped until he found the one with my suitcase. So I do have the world's most amazing spouse. You know, the story itself is so revealing, Katie, because it describes something that I think happens to all of us. I feel like, you know, on a routine basis, I open my email to send a note to my friend, but when I open my email, I see an urgent email from someone else and answering that email requires me to go look up a study. And 45 minutes later, I look up, I realize, I haven't sent that note to my friend.
直到他找到那辆有我手提箱的公交车。所以我确实拥有世界上最了不起的配偶。你知道，这个故事本身就非常具有启发性，凯蒂，因为它描述了我认为我们所有人都会遇到的事情。我觉得，你知道，在日常生活中，我打开电子邮件给朋友写便条，但当我打开电子邮件时，我看到了别人发来的紧急邮件，回复那封邮件需要我去查找一项研究。45分钟后，我抬头一看，意识到我还没有给我的朋友写那张便条。
Does something like that happen to you all the time too? All the time, absolutely. Yes. So, being distracted is one pitfall. I want to talk about another another which is being impulsive. We often make decisions quickly and then regret them later on. I'm thinking of this classic scene from Seinfeld where the character George Costanza gets upset and tells his boss exactly what he thinks of him.
这种事情也会一直发生在你身上吗？一直，绝对是。是的。所以，分心是一个陷阱。我想谈谈另一个陷阱，那就是冲动。我们经常快速做出决定，然后事后后悔。我想到《宋飞正传》里的经典场景，角色乔治·科斯坦扎生气了，并告诉他的老板他对他到底是怎么想的。
This is it. I'm done. Through. It's over. I'm gone. Finished. Over. I will never work for you again. Look at you. You think you're an important man? Is that what you think? You are a laughing stock. You are a joke. These people are laughing at you. You're nothing. You have no brains, no ability, nothing. I quit. So, Katie, you once dashed off a note to a colleague because you were really upset. And you dashed off this note somewhat impulsively. Do you remember the incident, what happened, what you said, and what the fallout was? Well, first, this has happened more than once, that I sent an e-mail.
就是这样。我受够了。结束了。完了。我走了。结束了。再也不会为你工作了。看看你。你以为你是个重要人物？你是这么想的吗？你是个笑柄。你是个笑话。这些人都在嘲笑你。你什么都不是。你没有头脑，没有能力，什么都没有。我不干了。所以，凯蒂，你曾经因为非常生气而给同事写了一张便条。你有些冲动地写下了这张便条。你还记得那次事件吗，发生了什么，你说了什么，后果是什么？嗯，首先，这种情况发生过不止一次，我发送了一封电子邮件。
But the one I had in mind was sent just a couple of weeks ago. It was a co-author team. Someone was inquiring about whose name will come first on this paper and I wrote a hot, short email saying, obviously the doctoral student who led this project, without recognizing there were egos involved and maybe I should write a slightly more politic note to express why I think this is the right resolution. It was a huge mistake.
但我脑子里想的那封是几周前发的。那是一个合著者团队。有人在询问这篇论文上谁的名字排在第一位，我写了一封火药味十足的简短邮件，说显然是领导这个项目的博士生，却没有意识到其中涉及自尊心，也许我应该写一封稍微委婉一点的便条来表达为什么我认为这是正确的解决方案。这是一个巨大的错误。
It could have been handled so much more elegantly, it would have saved everyone time and headaches and improved relationships, but sometimes we're impulsive. I have to ask, what was the fallout of it? I mean, was there any consequence to dashing off this note impulsively? Did you have to then spend time in some ways growing back into the right answer? Yes. So much time rolling back. So many carefully crafted apology emails to many different people explaining,
本来可以处理得更优雅，它会节省大家的时间和头痛，并改善关系，但有时我们很冲动。我必须问，后果是什么？我的意思是，冲动地写下这张便条有什么后果吗？你是否不得不花时间以某种方式挽回局面？是的。花了很多时间挽回。给许多不同的人写了许多精心构思的道歉邮件，解释说，
I'm so sorry, I should have explained my logic, I should have said this, I should have picked up the phone, it was a mess. In addition to being distracted and impulsive, many of us are also just plain forgetful. We promise to do something or be somewhere, and then it slips our mind. These self-inflicted injuries can be costly. Katie remembered one time she made an appointment with an important colleague. Dean Carlin, a professor at Kellogg's School of Management at Northwestern University, was visiting Philadelphia.
我很抱歉，我应该解释我的逻辑，我应该说这些，我应该拿起电话，这真是一团糟。除了分心和冲动，我们许多人也只是单纯的健忘。我们承诺做某事或去某地，然后就忘了。这些自残行为代价高昂。凯蒂记得有一次她和一位重要的同事约好了见面。西北大学凯洛格管理学院的教授迪恩·卡林当时正在访问费城。
We'd made a breakfast date to get together on a Monday morning. He confirmed it on Friday beforehand. I'll see you on Monday at 7.30. He was coming right to a coffee shop down the street from my apartment. And I got an email about 30 minutes after that date asking, you know, did one of us go for,
我们定好了周一早上一起吃早餐。他在周五提前确认了。周一早上7点半见。他正要来我家街对面的一家咖啡馆。我在那个约会后大约30分钟收到了一封电子邮件，问，你知道，我们中有人去吗，
he was trying to figure out where I was because I completely forgot. And when about my morning routine as usual and It hadn't even occurred to me that there could be something going on that was out of the ordinary that day was pretty embarrassing So we've looked at the idea of being Distractable impulsive and forgetful of for many people another defining problem they face is the challenge of laziness We let you know the dishes pile up in the sink, ignore the leaking faucet, we tell ourselves we'll get to the gym next week.
他试图弄清楚我在哪里，因为我完全忘了。我像往常一样过我的早晨例行公事，甚至没想到那天可能会发生什么不寻常的事情，这太尴尬了。所以我们研究了分心、冲动和健忘的想法，对许多人来说，他们面临的另一个决定性问题是懒惰的挑战。我们让水槽里的盘子堆积如山，忽略漏水的水龙头，我们告诉自己下周再去健身房。
And of course, many of us are also lazy in the workplace. I want to play your clip from the movie, Office Space. Employee Peter Gibbons has asked how he spends a typical day. And rather than come up with a usual bunk, he decides to tell the truth. Well, I generally come in at least 15 minutes late. I use the side door, that way lumber can't see me. And after that, I just sort of space out for about an hour. Space out?
当然，我们许多人在工作场所也很懒。我想播放一段电影《办公空间》的片段。员工彼得·吉本斯被问及他典型的一天是怎么度过的。他没有编造通常的谎话，而是决定说实话。嗯，我通常至少迟到15分钟。我走侧门，这样兰伯就看不见我了。在那之后，我就在那儿发呆大约一个小时。发呆？
Yeah, I just stare at my desk, but it looks like I'm working. I do that for probably another hour after launch too. I'd say in a given week, I probably only do about 15 minutes of real actual work. So Katie, you seem like an overachiever. I suspect that you are not prone to laziness, but does any of this ring true for you? Absolutely. And I think laziness isn't always spacing out when you're sitting at your desk. It can also be just, if there's some way that someone else I could hand this off to them
是的，我只是盯着我的桌子，但看起来我在工作。午餐后我也可能再那样做大约一个小时。我想在给定的一周里，我可能只做了大约15分钟真正的实际工作。所以凯蒂，你看起来是个追求卓越的人。我怀疑你不容易懒惰，但这其中有什么让你产生共鸣吗？绝对有。而且我认为懒惰并不总是坐在桌子前发呆。它也可以是，如果有什么方法可以让别人接手，
or I could take a shorter route to getting to my desired outcome. In fact, the work that I did originally exploring behavior change was motivated by a challenge I had, which was that I could not motivate myself to get to the gym at the end of a long day of classes and graduate school. I just couldn't. And so that's part of the impetus that led me to start studying this topic. I want to put one last idea on the table, Katie, and this comes from the Nobel Prize-winning economist Richard Faehlur. Many years ago, he had some guests over for dinner, and he put out a bowl of cashews
或者我可以走捷径达到我想要的结果。事实上，我最初探索行为改变的工作是由我面临的一个挑战激发的，那就是在漫长的课程和研究生学习结束后，我无法激励自己去健身房。我就是做不到。所以这就是促使我开始研究这个主题的部分动力。凯蒂，我想提出最后一个想法，这来自诺贝尔奖得主经济学家理查德·塞勒。多年前，他请了一些客人来吃晚饭，他放了一碗腰果
as an appetizer. Even though the guests knew that eating a lot of cashews would ruin their appetite for dinner, they couldn't stop themselves. How do temptations often derail us from reaching our aspirations? Yeah, I love that story because it's one of the things that led Richard Thaler to start studying what economists now call present bias, or the tendency we have to overweight whatever will provide instant gratification when we're doing a calculation and choosing between options and to undervalue anything that will give us long-term rewards.
作为开胃菜。尽管客人们知道吃很多腰果会破坏他们吃晚饭的胃口，但他们无法阻止自己。诱惑是如何经常让我们偏离实现愿望的轨道的？是的，我喜欢那个故事，因为它是促使理查德·塞勒开始研究经济学家现在所说的“当下偏见”的事情之一，或者说我们倾向于在计算和选择方案时，过度权衡任何能提供即时满足感的东西，而低估任何能带来长期回报的东西。
So that tasty cashew is in front of me right now. I know the dinner will be better, but I just can't resist because the instant gratification I'll get from popping one more in my mouth looms large since it's coming at this moment. It's also what leads us not to exercise and to sit on the couch, even though we know it would be good for us. It's what leads us to buy that shiny new gadget instead of setting aside the dollars we've earned for retirement. And so present bias is one of the most pernicious obstacles we face when it comes to achieving our goals, as you can see from those examples.
所以那个美味的腰果现在就在我面前。我知道晚饭会更好，但我就是无法抗拒，因为我从再吃一个中获得的即时满足感显得很大，因为它是在这一刻到来的。这也是导致我们不锻炼而坐在沙发上的原因，尽管我们知道这对我们有好处。这导致我们购买那个闪亮的新玩意儿，而不是把我们赚的钱存起来养老。所以，正如你从这些例子中看到的那样，当下偏见是我们实现目标时面临的最有害的障碍之一。
Yeah. What's striking to me also is that, you know, I think a lot of us recognize these limitations. We recognize that we are easily distracted, that we're impulsive, that we're lazy, we're prone to temptations. But very often, the insight alone is insufficient to overcome the problem. So just knowing, for example, that last week, I had trouble going to the gym, or last week, I was tempted by that extra large dessert. Doesn't mean that when the dessert is placed before me today I'm able to resist it. So in other words, the mere insight into the problem isn't sufficient as a solution
是的。让我感到震惊的还有，你知道，我认为我们很多人都认识到了这些局限性。我们认识到我们很容易分心，我们很冲动，我们很懒，我们容易受到诱惑。但通常情况下，仅有洞察力不足以克服这个问题。所以，仅仅知道，例如，上周我很难去健身房，或者上周我被那个超大份的甜点诱惑了。并不意味着当今天甜点摆在我面前时，我就能抵制它。换句话说，仅仅对问题有洞察力不足以作为解决方案
That's absolutely right. So it's a first step It's useful to have some insight into yourself because then you can begin to design solutions You can begin to look for solutions and science has actually a lot of solutions to offer And I know we'll talk about that, but it's absolutely insufficient. Knowing this is going to be a problem does not protect you. If knowing about the challenges we face isn't enough to overcome them, what can we do to chart a path to where the outcomes we want? When we come back, how Katie and other researchers have come up with brain hacks to help us fight our flaws.
这绝对正确。所以这是第一步。对自己有一些洞察力是有用的，因为这样你就可以开始设计解决方案。你可以开始寻找解决方案，科学实际上有很多解决方案可以提供。我知道我们会谈论这个，但这绝对是不够的。知道这会是一个问题并不能保护你。如果了解我们面临的挑战不足以克服它们，我们能做些什么来规划一条通往我们想要的结果的道路呢？当我们回来时，凯蒂和其他研究人员是如何想出大脑技巧来帮助我们对抗我们的缺陷的。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all have things we want to change about ourselves. But in spite of our best intentions, many of us sabotage ourselves. How? By being impulsive, forgetful, and lazy. These very human weaknesses make for great television comedy, but when they affect us, they can keep us from becoming the best version of ourselves. Katie Milkman is the author of How to Change, the science of getting from where you are, to where you want to be. In the book, she explains how we can turn our weaknesses on their head, how we can get them to work for us. Katie, in Stockholm, Swedish engineers wanted to encourage pedestrians to take the stairs
你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们都有想要改变自己的地方。但尽管我们有最好的意图，我们许多人还是会自我破坏。怎么做？通过变得冲动、健忘和懒惰。这些非常人性化的弱点造就了伟大的电视喜剧，但当它们影响我们时，它们会阻止我们成为最好的自己。凯蒂·米尔克曼是《如何改变》的作者，这本书讲述了从你所在的地方到达你想去的地方的科学。在书中，她解释了我们如何将弱点颠倒过来，如何让它们为我们服务。凯蒂，在斯德哥尔摩，瑞典工程师想鼓励行人走楼梯
over taking the escalator in a metro station. So they did something interesting. Can you tell me what they did? What they did is they created a set of piano stairs. So if you walked up the stairs, suddenly you heard a musical scale. And as a result of this change, people coming out of the Metro, they encounter this magnificent artistic musical creation and have the opportunity to make music on their way up instead of writing on the escalator.
而不是乘坐地铁站的自动扶梯。所以他们做了一些有趣的事情。你能告诉我他们做了什么吗？他们做的是创造了一组钢琴楼梯。所以如果你走上楼梯，突然你会听到一个音阶。由于这种改变，从地铁出来的人们，他们遇到了这种宏伟的艺术音乐创作，并有机会在向上走的时候创作音乐，而不是乘坐自动扶梯。
And of course, naturally, it's much more attractive. And it was a small experiment, a short-term experiment, but the finding was that 66% more people chose to take the stairs than usual. So what I'm getting from this idea is that in some ways when we are lazy, one way to combat that laziness in some ways is to make things more fun. And in some ways it seems almost obvious when you say it that way, but our desire for short term gratification, for being able to play a tune as we are running up and down the stairs, in some ways can be used to fight our tendency towards laziness. Exactly. And even though it does sound obvious when you say it, what's so fascinating is that research shows that is not our intuition. When we think about how we're going to achieve a
当然，自然地，它更具吸引力。这是一个小实验，一个短期实验，但结果是比平时多66%的人选择走楼梯。所以我从这个想法中得到的是，在某种程度上，当我们懒惰时，对抗这种懒惰的一种方法是让事情变得更有趣。当你这样说时，在某种程度上似乎几乎是显而易见的，但我们对短期满足感的渴望，为了能够在跑上跑下楼梯时演奏一段曲子，在某种程度上可以用来对抗我们懒惰的倾向。正是如此。尽管当你这样说时，它听起来确实很明显，但最令人着迷的是，研究表明这并不是我们的直觉。当我们考虑我们将如何实现一个
difficult goal, research by IELAT Fishbach, the University of Chicago and Caitlin Wolley at Cornell University has shown only a small minority of people look for the most fun way to pursue their goal. But their research has shown that if we actually instruct people, if you're at the gym, for instance, pick the most fun workout you can do instead of the most effective. Or if you're trying to stick to a healthy new diet, pick the most fun way of pursuing that instead of the toughest way, the way that will be most effective, you see better results. Giving kids also a fun way to do their math problem sets turns out to improve their persistence.
困难的目标时，芝加哥大学的艾拉特·费什巴赫和康奈尔大学的凯特琳·沃利的研究表明，只有少数人会寻找最有趣的方式来追求他们的目标。但他们的研究表明，如果我们实际上指导人们，例如，如果你在健身房，选择你能做的最有趣的锻炼，而不是最有效的。或者如果你试图坚持一种健康的饮食，选择最有趣的方式来追求它，而不是最艰难的方式，即最有效的方式，你会看到更好的结果。给孩子们一个有趣的方式来做他们的数学题集，结果证明能提高他们的毅力。
So the thing is that we're focused when we're making decisions on how do we get to our end goal, and we don't think enough about this obstacle that if we don't enjoy it, we're going to quit quickly, then we can make much more progress by looking for a fun way to pursue our goals. So you talked earlier in our chat about how you sometimes found it difficult to go to the gym when you were a graduate student. You came up with a technique to overcome your reluctance to go to the gym, and it involved a technique that you call temptation bundling. What do you mean by that, Katie?
所以问题在于，我们在做决定时专注于我们如何达到最终目标，而我们没有充分考虑这个障碍，即如果我们不享受它，我们很快就会放弃，那么通过寻找一种有趣的方式来追求我们的目标，我们可以取得更大的进步。所以你在我们之前的聊天中谈到了你作为研究生时有时觉得去健身房很困难。你想出了一种技术来克服你不愿去健身房的心理，它涉及一种你称之为“诱惑捆绑”的技术。凯蒂，你是什么意思？
I love that you asked about temptation bundling, and I should say, I did this research on temptation bundling, and I did temptation bundle as a person before I knew anything about the importance of making it fun, and frankly, before that work had been done itself. The idea came to me because I had two problems. One, I was struggling to get to the gym. The other problem that I didn't tell you about is when I came home from a long day of classes,
我很高兴你问到诱惑捆绑，我应该说，我做了关于诱惑捆绑的研究，而且在我知道让它变得有趣的重要性之前，坦率地说，在那个工作本身完成之前，我就已经作为一个人在进行诱惑捆绑了。这个想法之所以出现在我脑海中，是因为我有两个问题。第一，我很难去健身房。我没有告诉你的另一个问题是，当我从漫长的课程中回到家时，
all I wanted to do was curl up on the couch with a juicy page churner or binge watch TV. I just wanted entertainment. And so I was wasting all this time. I wasn't getting to the gym and I wasn't getting my work done. And I had this insight, which was what if I only let myself enjoy this indulgent entertainment that's wasting so much time while I'm exercising? And it was like magic. I started craving trips to the gym
我只想蜷缩在沙发上读一本引人入胜的书，或者狂看电视。我只是想要娱乐。所以我浪费了所有这些时间。我没去健身房，也没完成我的工作。我有了这个洞察力，那就是如果我只允许自己在锻炼时享受这种浪费了这么多时间的放纵娱乐呢？这就像魔法一样。我开始渴望去健身房
to find out what would happen next. I did it with page turners. I listened to audiobooks. So whatever, you know, the latest Harry Potter novel or Hunger Games novel that I was listening to, I just wanted to know what happened next. So I'm rushing to the gym.
去看看接下来会发生什么。我用引人入胜的书做了这件事。我听有声读物。所以无论是什么，你知道，我正在听的最新哈利波特小说或饥饿游戏小说，我只是想知道接下来会发生什么。所以我冲向健身房。
Time is flying while I'm there. I'm totally engrossed in the novel. I don't even notice the pain of the workout. And then I'm done. I come home refreshed ready to get my work done because I've gotten my entertainment fix. I've gotten my exercise in. It was incredible. My grades improved.
我在那里的时候时间飞逝。我完全沉浸在小说中。我甚至没有注意到锻炼的痛苦。然后我完成了。我回到家，精神焕发，准备完成我的工作，因为我已经得到了我的娱乐满足。我已经完成了我的锻炼。这太不可思议了。我的成绩提高了。
My spirits improved. And I realized, maybe it's not just me, maybe other people could benefit. And I call it temptation bundling because it was linking a temptation with whatever chore I was dreading so that I do more of the chore. The chore would cease to feel like a chore
我的精神状态也改善了。我意识到，也许不仅仅是我，也许其他人也能从中受益。我称之为诱惑捆绑，因为它将一种诱惑与我所畏惧的任何琐事联系起来，这样我就能做更多的琐事。琐事将不再感觉像琐事
and I do less of the tempting thing too. So you can do with other things in life, not just workouts, right? So you can only let yourself listen to your favorite podcasts while you're doing household chores or cooking a fresh meal or save particularly dolegant treats that you like to eat for times when you're studying or catching up on emails that you need to write or even a favorite restaurant you only visit with a difficult relative you should see more of. So there's all different ways you canation bundle. I understand that you sometimes schedule
而且我也能少做那些诱惑的事情。所以你可以在生活中用其他事情来做，不仅仅是锻炼，对吧？所以你可以只允许自己在做家务或做一顿新鲜饭菜时听你最喜欢的播客，或者把特别诱人的零食留到你学习或处理你需要写的电子邮件时，甚至是你只与你应该多见面的难相处的亲戚一起去的最喜欢的餐厅。所以你可以用各种不同的方式进行诱惑捆绑。我知道你有时会安排
difficult meetings that your favorite like burger restaurant. So, in other words, you're getting something even as you're giving something. Exactly. And it means there's a reason to look forward to that meeting and make sure that it does actually get on the calendar. So it also means though that if I ever get invited to that burger restaurant, I'll know exactly what you think of me, Katie. That's right. I've revealed the secrets. I'm not sure I can keep using it. Making difficult things fun and bundling temptations together with important tasks can
困难的会议在你最喜欢的汉堡餐厅。所以，换句话说，你即使在付出的时候也在得到一些东西。正是如此。这意味着有一个理由去期待那个会议，并确保它确实被列入日程。但这也就意味着，如果我被邀请去那家汉堡餐厅，我会确切地知道你对我有什么看法，凯蒂。没错。我已经揭示了秘密。我不确定我还能不能继续使用它。让困难的事情变得有趣，并将诱惑与重要的任务捆绑在一起，可以
help us overcome laziness and distraction. These techniques take the tendency of the mind to focus on short-term goals, and cleverly turns this weakness into a superpower. Another related idea that behavioral scientists have explored is about the power of breaking big targets into a series of smaller goals. And there's this wonderful research, Shlomo Benarzi, and Hal Hirschfeld at UCLA have done showing that if we invite someone to save $5 a day and they did this with a large savings app, people say yes to that at a far higher rate than if you invite them to save $35 a week or $150 a month, which if you do the math are exactly the same opportunity, but that bite size invitation, oh $5 a day, which if you do the math, are exactly the same opportunity.
帮助我们克服懒惰和分心。这些技术利用了思维专注于短期目标的倾向，并巧妙地将这种弱点转化为超能力。行为科学家探索的另一个相关想法是关于将大目标分解为一系列小目标的力量。加州大学洛杉矶分校的什洛莫·贝纳齐和哈尔·赫什菲尔德做了一项很棒的研究，表明如果我们邀请某人每天存5美元，他们用一个大型储蓄应用程序做了这个实验，人们答应这个要求的比例远高于你邀请他们每周存35美元或每月存150美元，如果你算一下，这完全是同样的机会，但那个一口大小的邀请，哦，每天5美元，如果你算一下，这完全是同样的机会。
But that bite size invitation, oh, $5 a day, it doesn't sound so momentous. And I can more easily accomplish that good outcome. So I want to talk about a slightly related idea, which is besides breaking things up into bite size goals, which is about setting targets, it's also really helpful to give people feedback in the moment about how they're doing. white-sized goals, which is about setting targets, it's also really helpful to give people feedback in the moment about how they're doing. There's something about receiving in the moment feedback that's really helpful in maintaining motivation to what our goals. Can you talk about that idea, Carrie, and are there studies that pointed that insight?
但那个一口大小的邀请，哦，每天5美元，听起来并不那么重大。我可以更容易地实现那个好的结果。所以我想谈谈一个稍微相关的想法，除了将事情分解成一口大小的目标，这关于设定目标，给人们关于他们做得如何的即时反馈也非常有帮助。一口大小的目标，这关于设定目标，给人们关于他们做得如何的即时反馈也非常有帮助。接收即时反馈在保持实现我们目标的动力方面确实很有帮助。凯莉，你能谈谈那个想法吗，有没有研究指出那个洞察力？
Yeah, and it's really important to provide feedback because we can't say we've had a success and respond to that success by celebrating and building on that success unless we know how things are going. There's a study I love that was done by a team looking actually at the benefits of real time feedback for water use of all things. And they gave different groups shower fauc, that either displayed how much water you were using in real time or simply tracked water use. And it was an experiment to see if that real time feedback would help people who were trying
是的，提供反馈非常重要，因为除非我们知道事情进展如何，否则我们不能说我们取得了成功，并通过庆祝和建立在那种成功之上来回应那种成功。我喜欢的一项研究是由一个团队做的，他们实际上研究了实时反馈对用水的好处。他们给不同的组提供了淋浴喷头，要么实时显示你用了多少水，要么只是跟踪用水量。这是一个实验，看看那种实时反馈是否能帮助那些试图
to cut back and be more environmentally conscious. And as you might expect, it was incredibly valuable to be able to see in real time just how much what are you using without that feedback. It's really hard to understand that you've accumulated a lot of what are used while you're in the shower, but when you're seeing it in real time, it's more salient, it's more vivid, and people cut back. So it's really interesting that in some ways a challenge
减少用水并更有环保意识的人。正如你可能预料的那样，能够实时看到你到底用了多少水是非常有价值的，没有那种反馈。在淋浴时很难理解你已经积累了大量用水，但当你实时看到它时，它更突出，更生动，人们就会减少用水。所以非常有趣的是，在某种程度上，一个挑战
is that when we are required to do something that pays off in the distant future, the value of exercise is not something we're going to see today or tomorrow, but it pays off in the distant future. It helps in some ways to manifest that future success in the present. That's what you're really doing, right?
是当我们被要求做一些在遥远的未来才有回报的事情时，锻炼的价值不是我们今天或明天就能看到的，但它在遥远的未来有回报。在某种程度上，这有助于在当下体现那种未来的成功。这正是你真正做的，对吧？
And when your treadmill tells you you have run four miles or burned 300 calories or whatever. It's not so much that the running four miles is meaningful, or the burning 300 calories is meaningful. What it's giving you is a little bit of motivation that tells you that you're on track for that longer term goal. That's absolutely right. You can figure out I'm making progress.
当你的跑步机告诉你你已经跑了四英里或消耗了300卡路里或无论什么。并不是说跑四英里很有意义，或者消耗300卡路里很有意义。它给你的是一点点动力，告诉你你正走在实现那个长期目标的轨道上。这绝对正确。你可以弄清楚我正在取得进步。
You can pat yourself on the back and feel better. Think of this as being related to gamification a bit, which is actually beneficial in general. If we have some way to be able to say, did I achieve the goal? Can I give myself a check for today or a gold star and pat myself on the back? You once conducted a study looking at how people make resolutions to go to the gym to get healthy.
你可以拍拍自己的背，感觉更好。把这看作与游戏化有一点关系，这实际上总体上是有益的。如果我们有某种方式能够说，我实现了目标吗？我能给自己今天的任务打个勾或贴个金星，拍拍自己的背吗？你曾经进行过一项研究，观察人们如何做出去健身房变得健康的决定。
And you found something striking about when people make these resolutions, that turned out to be quite revealing as a whole body of research. Can you tell me what the initial studies were and what you found? Yeah, and the question was just, is there some ideal moment when people are particularly motivated to change? So my then student who's now a professor at UCLA, Heng Chen Dai, and Jason Reese, who's a senior fellow at Warden and I, were all really fascinated and said to ourselves, we know that New Year's is a moment when people are particularly motivated to change. And I bet there are other moments that have that same sense of a fresh start, that same chapter break Feeling that you get at the beginning of a new year. So we we gathered a bunch of data sets and looked to see if there are other
你发现人们做出这些决定时有一些惊人的发现，这被证明是一整套研究。你能告诉我最初的研究是什么以及你发现了什么吗？是的，问题仅仅是，是否存在一个人们特别有动力去改变的理想时刻？所以我的当时的学生，现在是加州大学洛杉矶分校教授的恒晨戴，以及沃顿商学院的高级研究员杰森·里斯和我，都非常着迷，并对自己说，我们知道新年是人们特别有动力去改变的时刻。我敢打赌还有其他时刻具有同样的新开始的感觉，同样的那种你在新的一年开始时得到的章节结束的感觉。所以我们收集了一堆数据集，看看是否有其他
chapter breaks that showed similar jumps. So we looked it as you mentioned gym attendance We also looked at when people search for the term diet on Google and we looked at when people set goals on a popular goal setting website. And all of these data sets, what we saw was the same basic pattern where we saw spikes in the frequency of pursuing these goals at chapter breaks that include the start of a new week, the start of a new month, following people's birthdays, following holidays that we associate with new beginnings. So think more holidays like Labor Day or New Years and less holidays like Valentine's Day.
章节结束显示出类似的跳跃。所以我们看了，正如你提到的健身房出勤率，我们也看了人们何时在谷歌上搜索“饮食”这个词，我们看了人们何时在一个流行的目标设定网站上设定目标。在所有这些数据集中，我们看到的是同样的基本模式，我们在章节结束时看到了追求这些目标的频率激增，这些章节结束包括新的一周开始、新的一月开始、人们生日之后、我们与新开始联系在一起的节日之后。所以多想想像劳动节或新年这样的节日，少想想像情人节这样的节日。
And that was really the beginning of a line of work that Heng Chen and I in particular have spent a huge amount of time on looking at what it means to have a fresh start in life and how to use fresh starts to nudge behavior change. in life and how to use fresh starts to nudge behavior change. So I want to talk a little bit more about the idea of fresh starts because it's such an important and powerful idea. And I want to start in some ways with why you think fresh starts might have this effect.
那确实是恒晨和我特别花了很多时间研究的一系列工作的开始，研究在生活中拥有一个新开始意味着什么，以及如何利用新开始来推动行为改变。在生活中，以及如何利用新开始来推动行为改变。所以我想多谈谈新开始的想法，因为它是一个如此重要和强大的想法。我想在某种程度上从你认为为什么新开始可能会有这种效果开始。
I think all of us have had this experience of hitting an important milestone on a new birthday or even moving to a new city, for example, or a new country. And feeding like in some ways, you know, you can wipe the slit clean, you know, the past self in some ways is erased. And you can, you can begin afresh. What do you think is driving this at a psychological level? Yeah, I think you actually just gave a beautiful account of it. What our research suggests is that there's this identity break, there's a break point in our life that happens around these moments, and we actually think of life in chapters. So there might be, you know, the Boston years, the college years, the years working at
我想我们所有人都经历过在新的生日达到一个重要的里程碑，甚至搬到一个新的城市，例如，或一个新的国家。并且感觉在某种程度上，你知道，你可以把过去擦干净，你知道，过去的自我以某种方式被抹去了。你可以，你可以重新开始。你认为在心理层面上是什么在驱动这一点？是的，我想你刚才给出了一个美丽的描述。我们的研究表明，在这些时刻周围，我们的生活中存在这种身份断裂，存在一个断点，我们实际上以章节来思考生活。所以可能有，你知道，波士顿岁月，大学岁月，在埃森哲工作的岁月，
Accenture, you know, I don't, it depends on your life story, your life narrative. And at those break points, including the start of a new year, the celebration of our birthday, even the start of a new week, we feel like we're further from our past self. Who I was last year, that was the old me, this is the new me, or who I was last week, that was the old me, this is the new me, and that gives us license to say,
你知道，我不确定，这取决于你的生活故事，你的生活叙事。在那些断点，包括新的一年开始，我们生日的庆祝，甚至新的一周开始，我们感觉我们离过去的自己更远了。去年我是谁，那是旧的我，这是新的我，或者上周我是谁，那是旧的我，这是新的我，这给了我们许可去说，
well, their failures were sort of the failures of a different person. Yeah, last year I couldn't quit smoking or get an exercise routine going, but that was the old me, the new me can do it. So it gives us more optimism and we're also more likely it seems to step back and think big picture about our lives and our goals at those moments because they're disruptions to the day to day and those kinds of disruptions lead to more reflection.
嗯，他们的失败是不同人的失败。是的，去年我无法戒烟或养成锻炼习惯，但那是旧的我，新的我能做到。所以它给了我们更多的乐观情绪，而且在那些时刻，我们似乎也更有可能退后一步，从大局思考我们的生活和目标，因为它们是对日常生活的干扰，而那种干扰会导致更多的反思。
And most of the time when we try to set a goal or try to make a change, we do fall on our face maybe once, maybe twice, maybe 10 times. It's rare to succeed on your first try. So it seems really adaptive to me that we've developed these ways of setting those failures aside and feeling fresh motivation. I want to add one important caveat to the fresh starts literature, because in some ways what it's indicating really is the power of disruption in our lives. When we can come up with disruptions that actually are real disruptions, you know,
而且大多数时候，当我们试图设定一个目标或试图做出改变时，我们确实会摔倒，也许一次，也许两次，也许10次。很少能在第一次尝试时就成功。所以对我来说，我们已经发展出这些将那些失败放在一边并感受新鲜动力的方法，这似乎非常具有适应性。我想给新开始的文献增加一个重要的警告，因为在某种程度上，它真正表明的是我们生活中干扰的力量。当我们能够想出实际上是真正干扰的干扰时，你知道，
moving to a new city or a health scare, for example, or in some ways artificial disruptions, like the start of a new year or the start of a new season, it allows us to change things about our lives. But your work is also found that these fresh starts, in some ways, can be sometimes detrimental to people. Can you talk about when that might be? Yeah, this is actually work that Heng Chen-Dai, my former student, led.
搬到一个新的城市或健康恐慌，例如，或者在某种程度上人为的干扰，比如新的一年开始或新季节开始，它允许我们改变我们生活中的事情。但你的工作也发现，这些新开始，在某种程度上，有时对人们可能是有害的。你能谈谈那可能是什么时候吗？是的，这实际上是我的前学生恒晨戴领导的工作。
And we were both really interested in whether or not fresh starts might sometimes actually be harmful, particularly if people were having a lot of success. interested in whether or not fresh starts might sometimes actually be harmful, particularly if people were having a lot of success. So she had this really great idea to look at this not only in some laboratory experiments, but also in a study of major league baseball players. And players often get traded in the middle of a season, and you can think of that as a disruption, right, or kind of a fresh start. You move to a new city, you move to a new team, but there are some fresh starts that are
我们俩都非常感兴趣新开始有时是否实际上可能是有害的，特别是如果人们取得了很大成功的话。感兴趣新开始有时是否实际上可能是有害的，特别是如果人们取得了很大成功的话。所以她有一个非常好的主意，不仅在一些实验室实验中观察这一点，而且在对美国职业棒球大联盟球员的研究中观察这一点。球员经常在赛季中期被交易，你可以认为那是一种干扰，对吧，或者是一种新开始。你搬到一个新的城市，你搬到一个新的球队，但有些新开始是
a lot more dramatic than others. So there's two leagues in Major League Baseball, the American League and the National League. And if you are traded across leagues, all of your season-to-date statistics get wiped clean, and you have to start again. If you're traded within leagues, you actually get to maintain all your season-to-date statistics. So, Hengshan saw this really neat opportunity to look at players who were having a really good season-to-date and a really weak season-to-date. And one to see if there would be different effects of that cross-league trade relative to the within-league trade. And what she found is really
比其他的戏剧性得多。所以美国职业棒球大联盟有两个联盟，美国联盟和国家联盟。如果你被跨联盟交易，你所有赛季至今的统计数据都会被抹去，你必须重新开始。如果你在联盟内被交易，你实际上可以保留你所有赛季至今的统计数据。所以，恒晨看到了这个非常好的机会，去观察那些赛季至今表现非常好和非常弱的球员。并想看看那种跨联盟交易相对于联盟内交易是否会有不同的效果。她发现的是真的
exactly what she'd hypothesized when you're on a roll and you have that disruption, players who are performing above, well above average, those players actually ended up seeing their performance decline more when they're traded across leagues than within leagues. But for players who are having a week season, the cross-league trade is more helpful because again, you really want that reset when you've been having a tough time. I want to look at a real life challenge that is facing people in the United States and many other countries around the world, Katie. And that's how to get people to take the
正是她所假设的，当你处于顺境并且有那种干扰时，表现远高于平均水平的球员，那些球员在跨联盟交易时，表现下降得比在联盟内交易时更多。但对于那些赛季表现不佳的球员来说，跨联盟交易更有帮助，因为同样，当你经历了一段艰难时期时，你确实想要那种重置。我想看看美国和世界各地许多其他国家的人们面临的一个现实生活挑战，凯蒂。那就是如何让人们接种
COVID-19 vaccine. Some people are super ego to take it, of course, but there are many people who are hesitant. I understand that you've conducted a study that actually answers this very question and comes up with techniques in some ways to get people to be more willing to get vaccinated. Can you tell me about that work? Yeah, it was a huge team effort that we mounted
COVID-19疫苗。当然，有些人非常渴望接种，但有许多人犹豫不决。我知道你进行了一项研究，实际上回答了这个问题，并想出了一些技术在某种程度上让人们更愿意接种疫苗。你能告诉我那项工作吗？是的，这是一个巨大的团队努力，我们组织了
about a year ago when it was clear that figuring out how to encourage people to get a vaccine was going to be important to recovering from this pandemic. And we have a team of 150 scientists who we went to and we said, okay, we're going to partner on giant messaging studies with Walmart pharmacies and two local health systems, Penn Medicine and Guisinger Health, and test different communication strategies, encouraging people to get a vaccine, and see what works best.
大约一年前，当时很清楚，弄清楚如何鼓励人们接种疫苗对于从这场大流行中恢复将很重要。我们有一个由150名科学家组成的团队，我们去找他们，我们说，好吧，我们将与沃尔玛药房和两个当地卫生系统，宾夕法尼亚大学医学中心和盖辛格健康中心合作进行大型信息传递研究，并测试不同的沟通策略，鼓励人们接种疫苗，看看什么效果最好。
And we did this test in the fall of 2020, and we did it actually around flu vaccination so that we would know what changed a real vaccine decision, but we'd have the results in time to use the best tools for motivating COVID-19 vaccinations. So we tested ideas like telling people, hey, everyone else is getting a vaccine, you should too, or you should do this for the people you love to protect them.
我们在2020年秋天进行了这项测试，我们实际上是在流感疫苗接种周围进行的，这样我们就会知道什么改变了真正的疫苗决定，但我们会有结果及时使用最好的工具来激励COVID-19疫苗接种。所以我们测试了一些想法，比如告诉人们，嘿，其他人都在接种疫苗，你也应该接种，或者你应该为了你爱的人保护他们而这样做。
Or sending a joke, have you heard the one about the flu? Don't spread it around. Maybe that would be particularly memorable and funny. So there were all these different ideas and what we found at all three sites, an urban and a rural health system, as well as Walmart pharmacies and this test included over 700,000 Americans,
或者发送一个笑话，你听说过关于流感的那一个吗？不要传播它。也许那会特别令人难忘和有趣。所以有所有这些不同的想法，我们在所有三个地点发现，一个城市和一个农村卫生系统，以及沃尔玛药房，这项测试包括了超过70万美国人，
we found that the best performing message everywhere was a simple message reminding you to get the vaccine and saying it's been reserved for you or it's waiting for you. reminding you to get the vaccine and saying it's been reserved for you or it's waiting for you. And what we think is going on there is that when someone tells you this vaccine has your name on it, it's first it gives you the sense of ownership. And we know from research on something called the endowment effect that when you feel like something belongs to you, you're much more likely to want it, you're less willing to give it up, you value it more.
我们发现，各地表现最好的信息非常简单，就是提醒你接种疫苗，并告诉你疫苗已经为你预留或正在等你。提醒你接种疫苗，并告诉你疫苗已经为你预留或正在等你。我们认为其中的原因在于，当有人告诉你这支疫苗是为你准备的时，首先会给你一种归属感。根据关于“禀赋效应”的研究，我们知道，当你觉得某样东西属于你时，你更有可能想要它，更不愿意放弃它，也会更看重它。
So that might be part of the psychology. It also gives you the sense that this is being recommended. Why would your doctor reserve it for you? Why would it be waiting for you if they didn't think it was a good idea? And it may also seem like it's going to be easier to get it. It's already set aside for me. The hassle is going to be lessened. So for all those reasons we suspect, although we don't know for sure, this seems to be the
所以这可能是心理学的一部分。它也让你觉得这是被推荐的。如果医生不认为这是一个好主意，为什么要为你预留呢？如果不是好主意，为什么要为你准备呢？而且这看起来也更容易获得。它已经为我预留好了。麻烦减少了。所以出于所有这些原因，我们怀疑，尽管我们不能确定，但这似乎是
best performer. It's very clearly rising to the top in all three sites, and it's what we've been recommending. Others, who's were seeing it adopted now, which has been really exciting. I want to talk about one other limitation that can be turned into a super power, and that's the idea of ignorance. Usually ignorance is a bad thing, but if you don't know how difficult something is, it can sometimes become easier to accomplish. Can you tell me the story of George Dancing?
表现最好的方式。它在所有三个地点都明显脱颖而出，这也是我们一直推荐的方式。其他人，我们现在看到他们也采用了这种方式，这真的很令人兴奋。我想谈谈另一个可以转化为超能力的局限性，那就是无知的概念。通常无知是一件坏事，但如果你不知道某件事有多困难，有时反而更容易完成。你能给我讲讲乔治·丹齐格的故事吗？
I love this story. And I should say that Carol Dweck, who's a brilliant social psychologist at Stanford, is the person who taught me this amazing story. It's the story of a graduate student who walked into a class a little bit late. And there's a problem written on the board, actually a couple problems written on the board.
我喜欢这个故事。我应该说，斯坦福大学杰出的社会心理学家卡罗尔·德韦克是教会我这个精彩故事的人。这是一个研究生迟到走进教室的故事。黑板上写着一道题，实际上是几道题。
He jots them down, assumes their homework, and later goes back home, he's working on them. They're a little harder than usual, and he notices that, and he takes them a little longer to solve them than a typical homework set, but he eventually solves them, and he turns them in. What's so fascinating about this is that those were two unsolvable problems that had been written on the board.
他把它们记下来，以为是家庭作业，后来回家后就开始做。它们比平时难一点，他注意到了这一点，解决它们花费的时间比平时的作业要长，但他最终还是解决了它们，并交了上去。最令人着迷的是，黑板上写的其实是两道无法解决的难题。
So his professor discovers that George Danzig has actually solved these unsolvable problems and comes rushing and he tells him, oh my goodness, do you know what you've done? Believing these were just his regular homework problems is a big part of what helped George solve them. He didn't treat them any differently. He expected to find a solution.
所以他的教授发现乔治·丹齐格竟然解决了这些无法解决的难题，于是冲过来告诉他，天哪，你知道你做了什么吗？相信这些只是普通的家庭作业，是帮助乔治解决它们的重要原因。他并没有以不同的方式对待它们。他期望找到解决方案。
He persisted until he did. If he had thought they were insolvable problems, he might not ever have attempted them and never have had the success. Now, most of us are not mathematicians trying to solve unsolvable problems, but we can still see the relevance of George's experience in our own lives. If we don't know how many people have struggled and failed at a task we're about to attempt, we can approach that task with less trepidation.
他坚持不懈，直到成功。如果他认为这些是无法解决的问题，他可能根本就不会尝试，也就永远不会成功。现在，我们大多数人不是试图解决难题的数学家，但我们仍然可以在自己的生活中看到乔治经历的意义。如果我们不知道有多少人在我们即将尝试的任务上挣扎并失败，我们就能以更少的畏惧去接近那个任务。
We can focus on finding a solution rather than focus on the long odds that we face. When we come back, how we can employ one of the most important strengths we have as human beings, the capacity to plan years ahead to future proof our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've talked about the obstacles and challenges we face in changing our lives and habits. We are distracted and forgetful. We are lazy. We are impulsive. We've seen how we can get around some of our limitations
我们可以专注于寻找解决方案，而不是关注我们面临的渺茫机会。回来后，我们将探讨如何运用我们作为人类最重要的优势之一，即提前多年规划以实现未来生活保障的能力。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们已经讨论了我们在改变生活和习惯时面临的障碍和挑战。我们容易分心和健忘。我们很懒。我们很冲动。我们已经看到了如何通过行为技巧绕过我们的一些局限性，
with behavioral hacks, but this can be a constant uphill struggle. To really pull off the change we want to see, we need to do more than overcome the limitations of our present selves. We need to make things easier for the people we are going to become. We need to future-proof our lives. At the University of Pennsylvania's Wharton School, research a Katie Muckman studies how to do this. Katie, you talk about the idea of present me versus future me. What do those terms mean? Present me is literally living in the present.
但这可能是一场持续的艰苦斗争。为了真正实现我们想要看到的改变，我们需要做的不仅仅是克服当前自我的局限性。我们需要为未来的自己让事情变得更容易。我们需要为生活提供未来保障。在宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院，研究员凯蒂·米尔克曼研究了如何做到这一点。凯蒂，你谈到了“现在的我”与“未来的我”的概念。这些术语是什么意思？“现在的我”确实生活在当下。
All the decisions made in the present and all of the things consumed and enjoyed in the present, that's all that exists. Future me doesn't get to enjoy any of the delights of the present, the bowl of ice cream that's sitting in front of you is not available to future me, but future me will have to pay the consequences if you eat that bowl of ice cream every night. And so future me has a whole different set of objectives to optimize
所有在当下做出的决定，以及在当下消费和享受的所有事物，就是存在的一切。“未来的我”无法享受当下的任何乐趣，摆在你面前的那碗冰淇淋对“未来的我”来说是不可用的，但如果你每晚都吃那碗冰淇淋，“未来的我”将不得不承担后果。所以“未来的我”有一套完全不同的目标需要优化。
over. Future me is worried about having enough saving for retirement, worried about having excellent health and good relationships, and so they have very different objectives, as you can see in that, is where a challenge arises. The comedian Jerry Seinfeld has a wonderful summary of this idea, and I want to play you a clip of what he says. You ever do this like late at night, and you're watching TV, and I stay up late because I'm night guy. Getting up after five hours late?
“未来的我”担心是否有足够的退休储蓄，担心是否有健康的身体和良好的人际关系，所以他们有非常不同的目标，正如你所看到的，挑战就在这里产生。喜剧演员杰瑞·宋飞对这个想法有一个精彩的总结，我想给你播放一段他的片段。你有没有在深夜做过这种事，你在看电视，我熬夜是因为我是“夜间人”。五小时后起床？
That's morning guy's problem. That's not my problem. I'm night guy. Night guy. Night guy always screws morning guy's problem. That's not my problem. I'm night guy. Night guy always screws morning guy. Yeah, I'm curious. Because night guy has control of when you go to sleep. Morning guy has to get up. I feel I do this all the time myself, Katie.
那是“早晨人”的问题。那不是我的问题。我是“夜间人”。“夜间人”。“夜间人”总是搞砸“早晨人”的问题。那不是我的问题。我是“夜间人”。“夜间人”总是搞砸“早晨人”。是的，我很好奇。因为“夜间人”控制着你什么时候睡觉。“早晨人”必须起床。凯蒂，我觉得我自己也经常这样做。
I'm having so much fun doing something or agreeing to some new project. And I forget that I'm essentially binding future me to those very same choices. Absolutely. It's a major challenge and I think one of the most interesting things about human nature is this is one of the challenges that we really all face and some of us figure out that we have two selves and that they are in conflict and this is a challenge we need to resolve. But some of us go through life without paying
我做某事或同意某个新项目时玩得很开心。我忘记了我本质上是在把“未来的我”束缚在同样的那些选择上。绝对是这样。这是一个主要的挑战，我认为人性中最有趣的事情之一就是这是我们所有人真正面临的挑战，我们中的一些人意识到我们有两个自我，它们处于冲突之中，这是一个我们需要解决的挑战。但我们中的一些人过着生活，却没有注意
a lot of attention to this fact or trying to find ways to overcome it. So there's really interesting psychology and economics that comes into play though, once a person recognizes that they have this conflict and need to resolve it. So I wanna talk about some of the ways in which we can make our lives for our future selves
这一事实，或者试图找到克服它的方法。所以，一旦一个人意识到他们有这种冲突并需要解决它，心理学和经济学就会发挥非常有趣的作用。所以我想谈谈我们可以采取的一些方法，让我们的生活为未来的自己
better than they might be otherwise. And I wanna talk about some of these different ideas. The research at Dan are really wants our students to proofread the MIT newspaper and he allowed students to choose from three options. They could choose to meet a series of deadlines throughout the course, turn in all of their assignments on a single due date, or in the most flexible option, they could choose their own deadlines. Now, it might seem obvious that we all want the flexibility
变得比原本更好。我想谈谈其中一些不同的想法。丹·艾瑞里（Dan Ariely）的研究确实希望我们的学生校对麻省理工学院的报纸，他允许学生从三个选项中进行选择。他们可以选择在课程期间满足一系列截止日期，在单一截止日期前提交所有作业，或者在最灵活的选项中，他们可以自己选择截止日期。现在，我们似乎都想要灵活性
to choose our own deadlines, but what a Dan are really fine. What an economist would expect is that most of those people would set the deadline at the end of the semester, because that gives them the maximum time and a lot of his students Chose deadlines that were fairly evenly spaced throughout the semester just like a professor usually would do for you But they recognize that they might need that commitment to ensure they wouldn't let all the work pile up until the very end of the semester and if you compare the three groups of students and their performance, right, you have a group that can turn in their assignments whenever they would like,
来选择我们自己的截止日期，但丹·艾瑞里发现了什么？经济学家会预期大多数人会将截止日期定在学期末，因为这给了他们最大的时间，而他的许多学生选择了在整个学期中相当均匀分布的截止日期，就像教授通常为你做的那样。但他们意识到他们可能需要这种承诺来确保他们不会让所有工作堆积到学期末。如果你比较这三组学生及其表现，对吧，你有一组可以在他们喜欢的任何时候提交作业，
because there's no deadlines, a group that has evenly spaced deadlines, and a group that has invented their own deadlines. And the best performers on the last assignment, not hugely, surprisingly, are the ones who had the most stringent rules where the professor set evenly spaced deadlines for them throughout the semester.
因为没有截止日期，一组有均匀分布的截止日期，还有一组发明了他们自己的截止日期。最后一次作业表现最好的人，并不令人惊讶，是那些有最严格规则的人，即教授为他们在整个学期中设定了均匀分布的截止日期。
The second best performers were the ones who had the ability to choose deadlines that were earlier, some of whom took that opportunity. And then the worst performers were the ones who had an all at the end deadline and no constraints whatsoever, either imposed on them or available to them. Because indeed, they procrastinated and that last assignment got short-shift. Can you talk about another idea when it comes to future-proofing ourselves, Katie?
表现第二好的是那些有能力选择更早截止日期的人，其中一些人抓住了这个机会。而表现最差的是那些在最后期限前完成所有任务且没有任何约束的人，无论是强加给他们的还是他们自己可用的。因为确实，他们拖延了，最后一次作业被草率处理了。凯蒂，你能谈谈关于为我们自己提供未来保障的另一个想法吗？
And that's the idea that we can set up default policies that nudge our behavior in a certain direction. Researchers have looked at this in a number of different settings. What is the power of these defaults to help us overcome our present focused tendencies and care more about our future selves? Defaults are this amazing tool and what defaults do also is they harness our natural laziness but actually turn it into an asset rather than a liability. So the most famous study of
那就是我们可以设定默认政策，引导我们的行为朝着某个方向发展。研究人员在许多不同的环境中研究了这一点。这些默认设置在帮助我们克服以当下为中心的倾向并更多地关心我们未来的自我方面有什么力量？默认设置是一个了不起的工具，默认设置所做的也是利用我们天生的懒惰，但实际上将其转化为资产而不是负债。所以最著名的研究
defaults probably is a study that was done looking at people who were joining a new company that had a 401k plan, a retirement savings program. And you could sign up for the program on your first day as a new employee and they made it really easy to do it. For a long time, all you had to do on your first day of work was check a little box on some paperwork you're going to fill out anyway and say, yeah, why don't you go ahead and take a little bit of every paycheck and put it into this 401k I'd be delighted. Then they made a key change to their paperwork. I think it was in roughly 1998. Somebody said, let's just change the check box and say instead of checking a box to opt in,
默认设置的研究可能是一项针对加入一家拥有401k计划（退休储蓄计划）的新公司的人的研究。你可以在作为新员工的第一天注册该计划，他们让这变得非常容易。很长一段时间里，你在工作第一天所要做的就是在你无论如何都要填写的文书工作上勾选一个小方框，说，是的，为什么不从每份工资中拿出一小部分存入这个401k呢，我会很高兴的。然后他们对文书工作做了一个关键的改变。我想大约是在1998年。有人说，让我们改变一下复选框，说与其勾选一个方框来选择加入，
you can actually just check a box to opt out. We'll switch it up. And that tiny change had a huge effect on people's savings decisions. So people who joined the company just before this paperwork change and just after, you saw about a 35 percentage point increase in retirement savings signups when they were getting defaulted in and they just had to check a box to opt out, then if they joined the company before and had to check a box to opt out, then if they joined the company before and had to check a box to opt in. Because we take the path of least resistance, if I don't have to think, I don't have to check a box and it just happens, I can be lazy and the right thing will happen naturally. There's also this sense that this must be the recommended path or else why would it
你实际上可以只勾选一个方框来选择退出。我们来转换一下。那个微小的改变对人们的储蓄决定产生了巨大的影响。所以，在这次文书工作变更之前和之后加入公司的人，当他们被默认加入且只需要勾选一个方框来选择退出时，退休储蓄注册率增加了约35个百分点，而如果他们在变更之前加入且必须勾选一个方框来选择加入，则没有那么高。因为我们走阻力最小的道路，如果我不必思考，我不必勾选一个方框，它就发生了，我可以懒惰，正确的事情会自然发生。还有一种感觉，这一定是推荐的路径，否则为什么会
have been set as the default and why would they be giving the option only to opt out of what they've already set up for me? So between laziness and the implied recommendation, it's this hugely powerful effect. It's been shown to change all sorts of decisions from the prescribing of brand name drugs can be reduced by changing defaults dramatically. You can increase the number of people who agree to be organ donors and you can of course increase retirement savings. And again, just to be clear, in the case of the company,
被设置为默认值，为什么他们只提供选择退出他们已经为我设置好的选项？所以，在懒惰和隐含的推荐之间，这是一种极其强大的效应。它已被证明可以改变各种决定，从通过改变默认设置可以显著减少品牌药的处方。你可以增加同意成为器官捐赠者的人数，当然，你也可以增加退休储蓄。再说一次，为了清楚起见，在公司的情况下，
people have the same choice either way. They can elect to be part of the retirement savings plan or not. It's just that in one case, you have to elect to join the plan. In the other case, the default is that you're enrolled in the plan automatically, and you have to elect to be out of the plan. So, and in both cases, what you find is that people are reluctant even to take the effort to check the box of actually changing whatever the default is.
人们无论哪种方式都有相同的选择。他们可以选择加入退休储蓄计划或不加入。只是在一种情况下，你必须选择加入该计划。在另一种情况下，默认设置是你自动加入该计划，你必须选择退出该计划。所以，在这两种情况下，你发现人们甚至不愿意花精力去勾选那个实际改变默认设置的方框。
Exactly right, and it's really fascinating. It's a really powerful tool that a policymaker or employer, a benevolent government can use to try to help make it easier for citizens or, again, employees to end up with the best possible outcome because something has to be a default in most situations. So once you recognize the importance of them, you can try to be careful and thoughtful and choose defaults that will lead to good outcomes.
完全正确，这真的很迷人。这是一个非常强大的工具，政策制定者或雇主，一个仁慈的政府可以使用它来帮助公民或员工最终获得尽可能最好的结果，因为在大多数情况下，必须有一个默认设置。所以一旦你认识到它们的重要性，你就可以尝试小心谨慎，深思熟虑，选择会导致良好结果的默认设置。
It's also a powerful insight though for an individual who wants to improve their own outcomes that if we can set defaults in our own lives and take advantage of our own tendency to go with the default, it will help us make better decisions. So you can think about the way you stock your pantry, what the default foods are that are on hand. You can think about the default website. Your browser goes to if you want it to be not Twitter, but then your time's homepage, for instance, so that you get something that's full of enrichment as opposed to something that might take you down a rabbit hole. So there's lots of ways in our own lives we can set up defaults, including default savings contributions. Every paycheck you can have an automatic withdrawal that's sent straight to a savings account so that money just disappears and goes
对于想要改善自己结果的个人来说，这也是一个深刻的见解，如果我们能在自己的生活中设定默认设置，并利用我们自己倾向于遵循默认设置的习惯，这将帮助我们做出更好的决定。所以你可以考虑你储存食品储藏室的方式，手头有哪些默认食物。你可以考虑浏览器在你想要它不是Twitter，而是比如《纽约时报》主页时默认跳转的网站，这样你得到的是充满丰富内容的东西，而不是可能把你带入兔子洞的东西。所以我们可以在自己的生活中通过很多方式设定默认设置，包括默认储蓄缴款。每份工资你都可以进行自动扣款，直接发送到储蓄账户，这样钱就会消失并进入
right where you want it to go forever after. Another way to get defaults to work for you is to set up defaults not for your present self, but your future self. By recognizing you have two different people inside you and planning ahead, you can take advantage of the laziness of future you to stick to the default. of future you to stick to the default. There's this really interesting research that's been done by Richard Thaler and Shlomo Benarzi on a program they call the Save More Tomorrow program that shows people are more willing to save for retirement and able to save more when they're offered an opportunity to save in the future. So their future, self-ful experience, the pain not present me of saving.
你希望它去的地方，永远如此。让默认设置为你工作的另一种方法是，不是为现在的自己，而是为未来的自己设定默认设置。通过认识到你内心有两个不同的人并提前计划，你可以利用未来的你的懒惰来坚持默认设置。理查德·塞勒（Richard Thaler）和什洛莫·贝纳齐（Shlomo Benarzi）进行了一项非常有趣的研究，他们称之为“明天储蓄更多”（Save More Tomorrow）计划，该计划表明，当人们有机会在未来储蓄时，他们更愿意为退休储蓄，并且能够储蓄更多。所以他们的未来自我体验到了痛苦，而不是现在的我储蓄的痛苦。
But that future moment when they can save is actually when they next get a raise. So it's a moment when your income is going to increase. And so you can think, well, gosh, this isn't going to be all that painful, perhaps, because all the savings that you're asking me to set aside will come from money that's sort of gravy on top of what I'm used to taking home.
但那个他们可以储蓄的未来时刻实际上是他们下次加薪的时候。所以这是一个你的收入将会增加的时刻。所以你可以想，好吧，天哪，这可能不会那么痛苦，因为你要求我预留的所有储蓄都将来自我习惯带回家的钱之外的额外收入。
Now, you can also set up defaults that punish future you for not meeting your goals. You can drop a contract with your future self. If future you fails to deliver on a promise, future you will have to pay some large penalty, like giving away a large amount of money. And these kinds of cash commitment devices are tools that researchers proving can be really valuable to prevent future me from falling prey to present me's whims because now the price tag is too high and and we persist longer. We stick to our goals at a higher rate when it's too costly to fail. I remember we had a producer on Hidden Brain some years ago who was trying to kick the smoking habit.
现在，你也可以设定惩罚未来的你没有达到目标的默认设置。你可以与未来的自己签订合同。如果未来的你未能兑现承诺，未来的你将不得不支付巨额罚款，比如捐出一大笔钱。这些现金承诺设备是研究人员证明非常有价值的工具，可以防止未来的我沦为现在我的心血来潮的牺牲品，因为现在代价太高了，我们坚持得更久。我们以更高的比率坚持我们的目标，当失败代价太高时。我记得几年前我们在《隐藏的大脑》有一位制片人试图戒烟。
And we used a technique that Dean Karlin and Ian Ayers had come up with where he committed, the producer committed to making a large charitable donation, but not just to any charity. In this case, he was promising to donate the money to a nonprofit group that he hated. And now that makes it even more painful, because you're not just giving away your money, but you're giving away your money to a group that you really detest. And it turned out to be a very effective commitment device.
我们使用了迪恩·卡林（Dean Karlin）和伊恩·艾尔斯（Ian Ayers）提出的一种技术，他承诺，制片人承诺进行一笔巨额慈善捐款，但不仅仅是给任何慈善机构。在这种情况下，他承诺将钱捐给一个他讨厌的非营利组织。现在这让它变得更加痛苦，因为你不仅是在捐钱，而且是在把钱捐给你真正厌恶的组织。事实证明，这是一个非常有效的承诺设备。
Yes, I love that. I love the anti-charities. And this is one of the two most popular cash commitment and device websites is stickstkk.com. And that was actually founded by Dean and Ian, based on some of their research showing how effective this is. And they actually have a study that shows if you give people an opportunity to put money on the line
是的，我喜欢那个。我喜欢反慈善机构。这是两个最受欢迎的现金承诺设备网站之一，即stickk.com。这实际上是由迪恩和伊恩创立的，基于他们的一些研究，显示了这有多有效。他们实际上有一项研究表明，如果你给人们一个机会把钱押在赌注上，
that they'll have to forfeit in six months if they fail a nicotine or cotenine, you're in test. This is smokers, of course. If they put money on the line, it significantly increases their likelihood of quitting smoking over and above a control group that gets all the sort of usual bells and whistles on smoking cessation advice, but no money, and no commitment device that they can put on the line If they fail in fact, there was a 30% higher success rate among those who had access to this kind of a cash commitment device Hmm You're a fan of the writer Victor Hugo Katie and he came up with an astonishing
如果他们在六个月内未能通过尼古丁或可替宁测试，他们将不得不没收这些钱。当然，这是针对吸烟者的。如果他们把钱押在赌注上，这会显著增加他们戒烟的可能性，超过了对照组，对照组得到了所有通常的戒烟建议，但没有钱，也没有他们可以押在赌注上的承诺设备。如果他们失败了，事实上，那些可以使用这种现金承诺设备的人的成功率高出30%。嗯，你是作家维克多·雨果的粉丝，凯蒂，他想出了一个惊人的
Commitment device in order to finish writing his great novel the hunchback of Notre Dame Can you tell me what he did? Yes, absolutely. Victor Hugo was having trouble like all of us do with procrastination, and he was going out to parties. He was a big socialite, and he wasn't hitting his deadline. His publisher told him, you've got to do it. You've got to hit this, and he realized he had a problem. So he used a clever commitment device, which is he locked up his clothes. so he used a clever commitment device, which is he locked up his clothes. And the punchline is, because he couldn't go out in public
承诺设备，为了完成他伟大的小说《巴黎圣母院》。你能告诉我他做了什么吗？是的，绝对。维克多·雨果像我们所有人一样，在拖延症方面遇到了麻烦，他经常去参加聚会。他是一个大社交家，他没有达到他的截止日期。他的出版商告诉他，你必须完成它。你必须达到这个目标，他意识到他有一个问题。所以他使用了一个聪明的承诺设备，那就是他锁起了他的衣服。
anymore, he's naked, basically at home. All he could do was write. He's able to get this magnificent piece of literature finished. It's so interesting, Katie. So many of the ideas we're talking about here have echoes in the story from ancient Greek mythology involving Eulissi's and the song of the sirens. Can you tell me that story and how that idea has manifested and what are sometimes called
结果是，因为他不能再在公共场合露面了，他基本上在家里赤身裸体。他唯一能做的就是写作。他能够完成这篇宏伟的文学作品。这太有趣了，凯蒂。我们在这里讨论的许多想法在古希腊神话中关于尤利西斯和海妖之歌的故事中都有回响。你能告诉我那个故事，以及那个想法是如何体现的，以及今天有时被称为
Eulissi's contracts today, where people come up with ways to prevent their future selves from making bone-headed mistakes. Yeah, Eulissie was on this adventure and knew that he and his crew were aware that they were about to go past a legendary island inhabited by CNIMF's sirens whose song was so tempting and so sweet that every other crew that had gone past this island had been lured closer and closer to shore to listen to the sound of the sweet sirens voices. And they'd eventually all died because the closer you get to shore, the more likely you are to end up among these rocks that lead to shipwreck. So Elyseys knows he's coming up on this temptation that no one before him has been able to resist and that's led them all to perish. And he comes up with a strategy that's
“尤利西斯合同”的东西，人们想出各种方法来防止未来的自己犯愚蠢的错误吗？是的，尤利西斯正在进行这次冒险，并知道他和他的船员意识到他们即将经过一个传说中的岛屿，岛上居住着海妖，她们的歌声如此诱人，如此甜美，以至于每一个经过这个岛屿的船员都被引诱得越来越靠近海岸去听甜美海妖的声音。他们最终都死了，因为你离海岸越近，你就越有可能最终落入导致海难的岩石中。所以尤利西斯知道他即将面临这种没有人能抗拒的诱惑，这导致他们所有人都丧生了。他想出了一个策略，
going to allow him to get through at a commitment device. What he does is he says, okay, he wants everyone in his crew to plug their ears with wax so they won't be able to hear the sounds of the sirens and they won't be tempted to go off course, but he actually wants to experience their sweet song, so he asks his crew to bind him to the mast. So he will be unable to redirect the ship, but able to enjoy the sounds of the sirens voices without having any impact on his health and safety. And so this has become a famous example of a commitment device. He comes up with a way to bind himself in advance so that he can achieve his long-term goals without letting temptation get in the way of that good outcome.
这将允许他通过一个承诺设备度过难关。他所做的是他说，好吧，他希望他所有的船员用蜡塞住耳朵，这样他们就听不到海妖的声音，也不会被诱惑偏离航线，但他实际上想体验她们甜美的歌声，所以他要求他的船员把他绑在桅杆上。这样他就无法改变船的方向，但能够享受海妖声音的旋律，而不会对他的健康和安全产生任何影响。所以这成为了承诺设备的一个著名例子。他想出了一种提前束缚自己的方法，这样他就可以实现他的长期目标，而不让诱惑阻碍那个好的结果。
So if we can plan in advance, present bias isn't such a problem. And if we can plan in advance knowing present bias is coming down the line, it will try to bite us. It will try to take us off course. While planning and advance is the best tactic we can use to avoid ever falling prey to that challenge. One of the things I'm taking away from our conversation in General Katie is the importance in some ways of seeing our foibles and flaws, not in judgmental terms, but in sort of non-judgmental terms.
所以如果我们能提前计划，当下偏见就不会成为一个大问题。如果我们能提前计划，知道当下偏见即将到来。它会试图咬我们。它会试图让我们偏离航线。虽然提前计划是我们能用来避免沦为那个挑战牺牲品的最好策略。我从我们的一般谈话中带走的一件事，凯蒂，在某种程度上是看到我们的怪癖和缺陷的重要性，不是用评判性的术语，而是用非评判性的术语。
It's striking as I was reading your book, I discovered something that I hadn't known before. You actually studied to be an engineer at one point. And in some ways, this whole approach of thinking about our minds almost as engineering problems, I think, comes across very clearly in this book, which is you're not sort of being judgmental or wagging a finger or saying you're a bad person for being impulsive or easily Distracted or lazy. You're saying these are just the ways our minds work. How do we design in some way solutions to protect us from ourselves? Can you talk about that idea that in some ways being non-judgmental about ourselves can help us become the people we want to be? Yeah, it really is the key premise of the book and I do think because I learned to think like an engineer about problem-solving to recognize,
当我读你的书时，我发现了一些我以前不知道的事情，这很引人注目。你实际上曾经学习成为一名工程师。在某种程度上，这种几乎把我们的思想当作工程问题来思考的整个方法，我认为在这本书中表现得非常清楚，那就是你不是在评判，也不是在指责，或者说因为冲动或容易分心或懒惰而说你是一个坏人。你是在说这些只是我们大脑工作的方式。我们如何以某种方式设计解决方案来保护我们自己免受我们自己的伤害？你能谈谈那个想法吗，即在某种程度上，对自己不加评判可以帮助我们成为我们想成为的人？是的，这确实是这本书的关键前提，我确实认为因为我学会了像工程师一样思考问题解决，去认识到，
you can't solve a problem unless you understand the forces of opposition and then strategically overcome them. If there's one lesson really that's come from almost 20 years of research on behavioral science and trying to change behavior for the better. It is that too often we don't think, like engineers, we just look for a one-size-fits-all solution to problems and don't take the time to figure out what is the obstacle I need to overcome. And I think being non-judgmental but analytical about those problems is critical to allowing us to see the solution,
除非你了解对立的力量，否则你无法解决问题，然后战略性地克服它们。如果说行为科学近20年的研究和试图改变行为以变得更好真的有一个教训的话。那就是我们太频繁地不思考，像工程师一样，我们只是寻找一种万能的解决方案来解决问题，而不花时间去弄清楚我需要克服的障碍是什么。我认为对这些问题不加评判但进行分析对于允许我们看到解决方案至关重要，
to see the path to the best possible outcome. And I hope people take one thing away from the book from my research, even from this conversation. It would be that the importance of thinking strategically of recognizing once you understand what your limitations are, what's holding you back, you can be much more successful because you can work around them.
看到通往尽可能最好结果的路径。我希望人们从书中，从我的研究中，甚至从这次谈话中带走一件事。那就是战略性思考的重要性，认识到一旦你了解了你的局限性是什么，是什么在阻碍你，你就可以更成功，因为你可以绕过它们。
Kati Muthman is a behavioral scientist at the University of Pennsylvania's Wharton School. She's the author of How to Change, the science of getting from where you are, to where you want to be. Kati, I've wanted to have you on the show for a very long time. Thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
凯蒂·米尔克曼（Katy Milkman）是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的行为科学家。她是《如何改变：从你所在的地方到你想去的地方的科学》（How to Change, the science of getting from where you are, to where you want to be）的作者。凯蒂，我很长一段时间以来一直想请你上节目。非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you so much for having me. This was tremendously fun. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Noreen Aladina at Stitcher. Noreen helps us keep an eye on the metrics for our
非常感谢邀请我。这非常有趣。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是Stitcher的诺琳·阿拉迪纳（Noreen Aladina）。诺琳帮助我们关注我们节目的指标，
show and thinks about ways we can grow the show and launch new projects. She loves podcasts and loves numbers, which makes her a very hidden brain on Sanghira. She's unwaveringly kind and always helpful. Thank you, Nuri. If you like this episode, please think of two people who would like our show and tell them about this episode. If you are new to podcasting, please show them how to subscribe. Word of mouth recommendations are the single most important driver of podcast listening, so if you're a fan of the show and want to help it succeed, take a moment and think of a couple of people who might enjoy hidden brain.
并思考我们可以如何发展节目和启动新项目。她热爱播客，热爱数字，这使她成为《隐藏的大脑》中非常隐藏的英雄。她始终如一地善良，总是乐于助人。谢谢你，诺琳。如果你喜欢这一集，请想出两个会喜欢我们节目的人，并告诉他们这一集。如果你是播客新手，请向他们展示如何订阅。口碑推荐是播客收听的最重要驱动力，所以如果你是节目的粉丝并想帮助它成功，花点时间想出几个可能喜欢《隐藏的大脑》的人。
Please reach out to them right away. As you've seen in today's episode, it's all too easy to get distracted. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请立即联系他们。正如你在今天的节目中所看到的，分心太容易了。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。